generalmente los secretos escondidos
dentro de los videojuegos tienen un tono
alegre e inocente pero eso no quiere
decir que no hayan escondidos por ahí un
par de secretos e interés lo
suficientemente siniestros como para
cambiar completamente la atmósfera un
juego y sacarnos un buen susto
[Música]
así que para variar las cosas del día de
hoy vamos a dar un recorrido por algunos
secretos y misterios escondidos por el
mismísimo [ __ ] vamos a ver los 6 terex
y secretos más siniestros y
escalofriantes
the witcher llegó a ser mundialmente
conocido mayormente por la serie de
netflix que introdujo al mundo a este
interesante universo y bueno el recado y
le ayudó un poco
charlene y que estuviera tan carita brom
veas es un poco su cara parece tallada
por los mismos ángeles pero mucho antes
de la serie de gerardo imágenes the
witcher fue y sigue siendo conocido
ampliamente por su gran saga de
videojuegos siendo the witcher tres wild
hand uno de los mejores juegos de mundo
abierto aún hasta la fecha y contando
con un mundo tan vasto y variado el
juego tiene muchos secretos de todo tipo
por hay uno que destaca sobre los demás
por ser algo inusual durante la misión
una torre llena de ratas un jugador
descubrió mientras estaba explorando la
torre que se te parabas en un lugar muy
específico esto ocurriría
a la estancia aparecería una figura
extraña vigilándote pero si te mojas de
tu posición la extraña figura
desaparecería de inmediato esto causó
que los jugadores intentarán ver con más
claridad quién o qué es la figura que
aparecía detrás de nosotros pero no
lograron nada afortunadamente gracias a
los trucos de movimiento y con ayuda del
modo fotográfico nvidia se logrará un
vistazo más cercano a la criatura pero
aún se mantiene como un misterio el que
es esa cosa o el por qué está ahí
harvest moon es una serie de juegos
mayormente para público infantil entrar
a construir una granja y la hora es cómo
construir tu hogar y cuidar de los
animales como dije enfocada mayormente
para público infantil y es por esta
misma razón por la cual es tan raro el
hecho de que en varios de estos juegos
se encuentran escondidos algunos
secretos bastante perturbadores uno de
estos secretos lo podemos encontrar en
una de sus primeras entregas pues si nos
ponemos frente al televisor encendido a
las 4 y 44 pasará lo siguiente
[Música]
al parecer esto ocurre ya que el número
4 la cultura japonesa se pronuncia igual
que la palabra muerte y es considerado
de mala suerte
[Música]
california despedida es un juego de
carreras estrenado en 1998 bastante
común sin nada fuera de lo ordinario
pero eso cambió con el jugador se
percató mientras jugaba una carrera que
en uno de los tantos carteles que
adornaban uno de sus escenarios había
algo distinto a los demás
acercándose lo más posible se descubrió
que dicho cartel tenía escrito el
siguiente mensaje a veces dios se llevó
a las madres ya los cachorros pero a
veces y sólo a veces yo lo hago por más
oscuro que parezca esto de hecho tiene
una explicación y es que uno de los
creadores del juego puso este mensaje
para que alguien de su equipo lo pudiera
notar fácilmente y cambiar el mensaje
por otra textura pero al parecer a todos
se les olvidó cambiarlo de acuerdo eso
lo puedo entender poner un mensaje para
que después sea reemplazado pero diablos
el enorme mundo de red dead redemption 2
contiene una increíble atención al
detalle al igual con enorme cantidad de
secretos y créeme te sorprendería saber
cuántos de estos secretos son
escalofriantes
uno de estos secretos lo podemos
encontrar si nos dirigimos a esta parte
del mapa en donde hallaremos una casa
abandonada si encontramos la manera de
entrar en esta casa esto es lo que
veremos
[Música]
explorando la habitación descubriremos
que la persona que vivía aquí intentó
crear mutantes artificiales con partes
de animales muertos otro de estos
secretos lo encontraremos aquí en este
bosque hallaremos un montón de cadáveres
de un equipo de atletas que fueron todos
asesinados por una sola persona
investigan nómadas por varias partes del
mapa podemos encontrar tres cadáveres
asesinados brutalmente y junto a cada
uno de estos cadáveres habrá una pista y
se reunimos las tres completaremos un
mapa que nos guiará a la ubicación de el
asesino un pequeño sótano lleno de
cuerpos donde tendremos la opción de por
fin acabar con él
en este juego de terror psicológico
podemos encontrar una genial referencia
al extinto juego de silent hill es que
iba a ser desarrollado por hideo kojima
más exactamente a su vimos jugable que
salió para playstation 4 para hace un
par de años un recuerdo muy hermoso
gracias
avanzando por el juego tarde o temprano
nos cruzaremos con esta puerta con el
número 202 la cual estará bloqueada pero
si damos un vistazo alrededor cerca de
la zona podemos encontrar oculta una
tableta caliente actuar con ella causará
que el monitor que estaba ubicado cerca
a la puerta se encienda y eventualmente
nos muestre el código para abrir la
puerta una vez abierta nos encontraremos
cambiando por un pasillo interminable
que cambiará ligeramente cada vez que
cruzamos por ahí prendiendo un tipo de
homenaje a las demos jugables de silent
hill 2
[Música]
en el juego de horror layers of fire en
la parte del sótano siempre habrá una
puerta que estará bloqueada en todo
momento pero curiosamente si configuras
tu consola con la fecha del 31 de
octubre la puerta se abrirá revelando
una pequeña habitación con una mesa y
una tabla ouija en la cual puedes
escribir lo que quieras pero si
introduces ciertas palabras específicas
ocurrirá lo siguiente
[Música]
ah
más
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
vengan él es un recuerdo que encarnará
son zombis llamado ed el cual es forzado
a participar en carreras y circuitos con
obstáculos y plataformas todo para
alcanzar a su amigo humano llamado ven
el juego es bastante simple lo aterrador
viene cuando completas el juego y
liberas el modo bengalí que es un modo
de juego en donde podrás usar a un
zombie benz para completar los distintos
mapas pero al llegar al último nivel del
juego esto es lo que ocurrirá te
recomiendo bajar un poco el volumen
[Música]
i
no [ __ ] casi me cago del susto cuando
llegas al final del juego se reproducirá
este siniestro vídeo y el juego se
cerrará sumado a esto en un área oculta
del juego también se encuentra un
mensaje indicando a los jugadores que
visiten un facebook con el nombre de ven
a esta página de facebook se dedicó por
un tiempo a subir imágenes y mensajes
crípticos como si estudiando pistas
acerca de algo al mismo tiempo algunas
personas dieron cuenta de que en cierto
momento del aterrador vídeo del final
del juego se pueden ver unas coordenadas
que resultaron ser de un lugar ubicado
en essen alemania un youtuber español
conocido como bears gamer se tomó la
molestia de ir él mismo hasta ese lugar
en donde encontró un ipad un par de
dibujos unas fotos y un hueso luego de
esto los desarrolladores del juego y ver
se pusieron en contacto según le
contaron a él ellos eran conscientes del
extraño vídeo al final del juego pero no
fueron responsables por él ya que al
final del desarrollo contrataron a un
tipo llamado benedick para que se
encargara la parte final del juego a
pesar de que ellos aseguran jamás haber
conocido un personal tipo solo contactar
con él por internet luego de esto tanto
el equipo de desarrolladores como el
youtuber bears decidieron ir a
investigar una casa abandonada que se
encontraba cerca del lugar donde
encontraron el primer paquete con las
fotos
batman mira el tamaño de esas bolas en
este lugar encontraron otro paquete con
más dibujos y otro hueso pero luego de
un tiempo en esta casa sintieron como si
alguien más estuviera ahí con ellos así
que decidieron salir del lugar asustados
por los sonidos y el presentimiento de
que alguien pudo haberlos estado
siguiendo
corre pernas con él
a 10 después de lo ocurrido en ese lugar
la página de facebook siguió subiendo
imágenes extrañas y mensajes sin ningún
sentido aparente hasta que en la página
de facebook apareció un link de un vídeo
llamado manifiesto en donde se veía un
hombre aparentemente cortándose su
propio pie por obvias razones no lo pudo
mostrar pero el vídeo es bastante
perturbador y no hizo más que crear más
dudas acerca de este misterio que ya
comenzaba a preocupar a la gente tanto
que a causa de esto la página de
facebook fue borrada a pesar de todo
esto al cabo de un par de semanas la
página de facebook volvió a surgir y
continuó subiendo más mensajes e
imágenes a lo largo de los años por el
momento estas son las últimas imágenes
subidas por la página de facebook muchas
personas creen que lo que sea que la
persona detrás de este facebook está
ocultando está en este lugar pero
desafortunadamente por más que la
comunidad intentará estos lugares no han
sido encontrados y el misterio parece
que nunca será resuelto hay muchas
teorías acerca de todo esto desde las
más simples diciendo que todo puede ser
una broma muy elaborada hasta las
oscuras que aseguran que quien está
detrás de todo esto puede ser un caníbal
que nos está dando pequeñas pistas de
dónde escondió a sus víctimas
después de todo tú decides
el youtuber werth gamer hizo un gran
trabajo de investigación con este caso y
le dedicó una gran cantidad de vídeos
muy interesantes así que si quieres
saber más a profundidad todo este caso
te recomiendo mucho visitar su canal
bueno fue un divertido viaje descubrir
esta lista con los sistemas siniestros
en videojuegos originalmente tenía la
idea de subir este vídeo en octubre del
año pasado pero se me olvidó en todo
caso espero que el vídeo te haya gustado
si quieres ver más sister exo cosas por
el estilo al final te dejaré un par de
vídeos para que les des un vistazo hasta
la próxima
[Música]